unverhofft kommt oft am 9 märz 2022
wurden in südkorea
präsidentschaftswahlen abgehalten eine
wahl die einen bruch in der politischen
tradition der legionen südkoreanischen
demokratie darstellt ich spreche hier
von üblicherweise alle zehn jahre
stattfindet den wechsel der
regierungsgewalt zwischen konservativen
und progressiven partei bündnissen also
nach zwei vollen amtszeiten der
präsidentin des jeweiligen lagers bei
der diesjährigen wahl liebe visuelle
politik fans liegt es jedoch erstmalig
vollkommen anders südkorea hat gerade
einen beachtenswerten politischen
umbruch erlebt nach nur fünf jahren
einer progressiven regierung sind nur
die konservativen wieder an der macht
wurde dies verdanken sie nicht
irgendeinem kandidaten habt ihr in
diesem zusammenhang vielleicht schon mal
folgendes video gesehen
[Musik]
tja das geschah nach der wahl als
reaktion auf den sieg in monza calls
also meine lieben zu short passt gut auf
denn heute verraten wollte alles
wichtige über diesen sehr interessanten
man dass ein land und die ganze region
in eine neue ära führen will
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hätte man noch vor 12 monaten gesagt
dass er nur ein jahr später der
präsident seines landes sein würde hätte
er darüber sicher gelacht der nun
gewählte südkoreanische präsident ist
eigentlich ein politischer außenseiter
bis zum märz 2021 war er der general
stars unweit seines landes für dieses
amt wurde ausgerechnet vom geschlagenen
präsidenten selbst ernannt ja welche
fieser piotr ist
[Musik]
als generalstaatsanwalt bei uns dafür
bekannt knallhart gegen korruption
vorzugehen er gilt zum beispiel als
architekt ina maßnahmen weil sie gar zur
verhaftung zweier ehemaliger
südkoreanische präsidenten führten
hierbei handelt es sich um den
ehemaligen konservativen präsidenten lee
myung bak und die ebenfalls konservative
ehemalige präsidenten im park ohne den
korrupte praktiken die bestechung und
einflussnahme vorgeworfen worden tja was
hätte generalstaatsanwalts nun wohl mit
einem steinmeier gemacht wenn diese
präsident von südkorea wäre so viel zu
den unterschiedlichen standards der
korruptionsbekämpfung in europa und
südkorea wir werden allerdings
feststellen dass es gar nicht mal jungs
tapfere kampf gegen die korrupten eliten
war der ihm den sieg bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen eindruck ein sieg
der übrigens mit einem nur sehr knappen
vorsprung ehrung wurde 48,56 prozent der
stimmen für die neuen präsidenten gegen
47,83 für seinen progressiven gegner das
heißt weniger als ein punkt unterschied
dies entspricht weniger als
250.000 stimmen
was aber könnte dann die ursache für die
abkehr von talis alternierenden
regierungswechsel zwischen konservativen
und progressiven nach jeweils zehn
jahren gewesen sein warum hat
ausgerechnet münchen als erster
präsident bereits nach seiner ersten
amtszeit das vertrauen der bevölkerung
in das progressive lager verspielt und
welche konsequenzen erwachsen daraus was
hält die zukunft für die koreanische
halbinsel bereit nun schauen wir uns das
alles doch mal etwas genauer an
für uns rbl
[Musik]
als moschee in den jahr 2017 zur wahl
antrat tat er dies mit einer reihe von
hoch gesteckten und rosig umschriebenen
versprechen hierfür müsst ihr wissen das
ist für einen präsidenten in südkorea
nicht möglich ist wie die idee zu werden
[Musik]
sondern ambitionierten ziele hätte man
also innerhalb einer amtszeit von fünf
jahren umsetzen müssen bevor ein
nachfolger aus dem gleichen politischen
lager die amtsgeschäfte übernehmen würde
unter anderem hatte wolf versprochen
weitreichende reformen in der
sozialpolitik der wirtschaft und
innerhalb des politischen systems selbst
durchzuführen diese maßnahmen zielten
unter anderem auf die nachhaltige
entflechtung der beziehungen zwischen
der politik und den chip-ball südkoreas
großen wirtschafts konglomeraten ab
darüber hinaus versprach er den sitz des
präsidenten ausgezogen heraus zu
verlegen und die zivile nutzung der
kernenergie zu beenden und obendrauf
kommen noch die beiden bedeutendsten
beteuerungen nun versprach das massive
problem der hohen wohnungspreise in
großem stil zu beheben und zu guter
letzt auch noch endlich frieden mit
nordkorea zu schließen wie sieht also
nun nach fünf jahren seine bilanz aus
man muss feststellen dass keines dieser
ambitionierten ziel ist vollständig
erreicht wurde und die regierung
gemessen an den von ihr gestellten
erwartungen als gescheitert betrachtet
werden muss selbst die vergleichsweise
kleineren ziele wie die verlegung des
präsidentenbüros aus zone heraus konnte
man nicht erreichen ein projekt welches
im übrigen nun von kürzlich neu
gewählten präsidenten angegangen wird
hierfür wird dieser sonderbare weise
jedoch von der partei seines vorgängers
scharf kritisiert ihr seht also auch in
südkorea ist die spitzenpolitik ein gut
dotierter kindergarten politik für das
volk sieht jedenfalls anders aus
jung und mond streiten über den umzug
des präsidentenbüros die abgeordneten
der demokratischen partei stellen die
eine frage und einige deuten an dass
juden geheime gründe haben könnte um
nicht in das blaue haus zu ziehen wie zb
feng shui das ist natürlich ein
amüsanter aspekt dieser kindergarten
politik aber was nun folgt ist weniger
lustig die ergebnisse von muss
energiepolitik zum beispiel sind
wesentlich folgenschwerer als moscheen
2017 an die macht kam kündigt er ein
plan zum ausstieg seines landes aus der
atomenergie an juni 2017 wir werten den
plan von nuklear orientierten
stromerzeugung ändern und den weg für
ein atomfreies zeitalter ebenen wir
werden die bestehenden pläne zum bau
neuer kernkraftwerke zurück ziehen und
die laufzeit von kernkraftwerken nicht
verlängern
tja manche ankündigungen sind im kontext
aktueller ereignisse einfach verdammt
schlecht gealtert denn als die preise
für erdgas erdöl und auch kohle
explodierten änderten sich diese
ansichten plötzlich grundlegend und muss
eigene regierung schien infolgedessen
schlagartig eine der atomkraft gegenüber
positiv eingestellte politik zu
verfolgen der erste koreanische handels
und eine die minister der das
kernkraftwerk an 0 in der region geboren
besuchte forderte eine rasche
fertigstellung der im bau befindlichen
reaktoren um angesichts der steigenden
rohstoffpreise eine lockerung der
politik des atomausstiegs anzuregen
natürlich ist die änderung einer
fehlerhaften politik klug jedoch bin ich
mir nicht sicher ob ein so kategorischer
richtungswechsel innerhalb von fünf
jahren ein gutes zeichen ist wenn man so
wie hier in mons mannschaft nicht
gleichzeitig in der lage ist zuzugeben
dass man einem irrtum erlegen ist und
das ist noch nicht alles wir fangen
gerade erst an zwar ist es war das muss
politik gegenüber nordkorea die längste
phase militärischer stabilität für die
koreanische halbinsel seite entspannungs
politik der neunziger jahre
hervorgebracht hat jedoch erwirkte er
für die beziehungen beider länder
dennoch keine nachhaltig positiven
ergebnis daran änderten auch die drei
bilateralen gipfel treffen mit kim
jong-un nichts und auch nicht die beiden
gesprächsrunde zwischen trump und kim
jong un bei denen man als vermittler
auftrat sicher habt ihr hierzu auch
schon mal sorgen das video gesehen oder
schaut euch auf jeden fall mal an
daher setzt nordkorea seine kampagne der
ständigen provokationen während der
präsidentschaft von monti in fortführen
jahren erprobte dutzende von raketen
unterschiedlicher reichweite beleidigte
in seinen staatlichen medien wiederholt
die regierungsorgan seines tödlichen
nachbarn und testete nur wenige monate
nach amtsantritt eine wasserstoffbombe
allerdings kam es während der amtszeit
nun zu einem stopp dieser atomtests und
die koreanische halbinsel wurde seit
viereinhalb jahren von nuklearen
detonationen verschont hier muss
allerdings nicht zwingend ein
zusammenhang bestehen genauso gut könnte
die entsprechende testphase des
nordkoreanischen atomprogramms einfach
abgeschlossen sein der höhepunkt der
provokationen trug sich im juni 2020 zu
als nordkorea das innerkoreanische
verbindungsbüro gestern ein symbol für
den dialog zwischen den beiden koreas
buchstäblich in die luft sprengte
und seitdem kam es zu keinerlei
diplomatischen forscher mehr es herrscht
eine eiszeit mit anderen worten
ungeachtet seine versprechen ist es
nicht gelungen ein friedensabkommen mit
nordkorea auch zu schließen und so dem
koreakrieg ein für allemal zu beenden
[Musik]
für diejenigen unter euch die es noch
nicht wissen offiziell wurde der korea
krieg im jahr 1953 gar nicht beendet in
ihnen ja wurde lediglich einen
waffenstillstand vereinbart technisch
und rechtlich gesehen befinden sich die
beiden länder also immer noch im
kriegszustand entgegen seiner
wahlversprechen ist es nun also nicht
gelungen dieses diplomatische ziel zu
erreichen und wisst ihr was vielleicht
ist es sogar besser so ich möchte mir
gar nicht vorstellen welche
zugeständnisse hätte machen müssen damit
er diesen plan wirklich umsetzen kann
und nun zur vollendung dieser liste
großer politischer misserfolge und
unerfüllte versprechen kommt der punkt
der vielleicht am meisten zur niederlage
muss beigetragen hat seine
wohnungspolitik fakt ist dass es mund
während seiner gesamten amtszeit nicht
nur nicht geschafft hat einen land bei
diesem großen thema voranzubringen im
gegenteil die dinge haben sich sogar
noch verschlechtert schaut euch mal
selber an
[Musik]
die immobilienpreise im großraum sohle
der am stärksten betroffenen region sind
seit der machtübernahme von moscheen im
jahr 2017 um 35 prozent gestiegen
betrachtet man den zeitraum ab 2015 sind
es etwa 50 prozent in einigen gegenden
der stadt haben sich die wohnraum preise
sogar mehr als verdoppelt warum das
einmal zu verdeutlichen möchte ein
südkoreaner heute eine wohnung in einer
fläche von 82 quadratmeter kaufen möchte
er im durchschnitt dafür mehr als 900
70.000 dollar ausgeben während die
gleiche wollen oder drei jahre zuvor
etwa 590.000 dollar gekostet hätte vor
diesem hintergrund waren die folgenden
schlagzeilen natürlich keine große
überraschung
traut versagen in der immobilien politik
ein immer zumindest in diesem fall haben
muss und sein team ehe versagen
öffentlich eingeräumt sicher könnt ihr
euch vorstellen dass die jungen wähler
welche nun im jahr 2017 noch voller
euphorie vertraut hatten recht
enttäuscht waren denn nun wurde damals
als das südkoreanische obama bezeichnet
nun ja wie hier bei visual politik waren
von den ergebnissen der von nun
eingeleiteten maßnahmen nicht gerade
überrascht denn die meisten seiner
angriffe zielten auf die begrenzung der
nachfrage ab nur sehr wenige dieser
erhöhung des angebotes an wohnraum so
weit so schlecht zusammengefasst waren
dies die schwerwiegendsten fehler weil
ich zum historischen kurswechsel in
südkorea geführt haben ein kurswechsel
der sich nur um haaresbreite und
offenkundig mit wenig enthusiasmus der
südkoreaner folgen hat aber nun ist bei
uns nie bewiesen politik fans die frage
stellen welche pläne der neue mann an
der spitze jens akyol für südkorea in
petto hat machen wir uns also ein bild
davon
die eragon was erwartet korea
durch den knappen sieg ihres steuert die
südkoreanische politik stürmischen
zeiten entgegen und dies gilt sowohl für
die innen- als auch für die außenpolitik
betrachtet darüber hinaus noch jungs
charakter damit ihr feststellen dass er
eine außergewöhnliche und nicht zu sagen
merkwürdige persönlichkeit ist
erklärt offen dass ein antifa minus zwei
während seines wahlkampfes hat er sich
sogar damit gebrüstet außerdem ist ein
anhänger der protestantischen
christlichen gemeinde ihlow von gospel
church dabei handelt es sich um eine
religiöse gemeinde mit rund 800.000
mitgliedern wie zu den konservativsten
in korea gehört und deren führer an der
spitze der anti lgbt bewegungen im land
stehen daneben ist der ehemalige
generalstaatsanwalt in wirtschaftsfragen
ein anhänger der theorien von mises &
friedman mit ihren standpunkten
hinsichtlich des freien marktes
hervorstechen er ist ein starker
befürworter von deregulierung und
niedrigen steuern und es ist davon
auszugehen dass seine regierung ein
technokratisches profil mit
entsprechenden leitlinien bekommt aber
lasst uns doch etwas konkreter werben
wir haben bis hierhin die faktoren
erläutert welche zur niederlage muss und
dessen regierungspartei führten nun
stellt sich allerdings die frage welche
antworten hat der neue präsident auf die
herausforderungen vor denen sein land
steht
[Musik]
nun zum einen hat er sich während seines
wahlkampfs dafür starkgemacht wieder auf
kernenergie zu setzen während muss
regierung den bau mehrerer atomreaktoren
gestoppt hatte glaubt der neue präsident
dass atomenergie die beste option für
südkoreas energieversorgung der nächsten
jahrzehnte ist und strom dadurch
reichlich vorhandenen billig und sauber
sein würde mit der ernennung der
experten so das präsidiale übergangs
komitee sitzen der neue präsident
bereits ein zeichen denn mehrere
mitglieder dieses komitees sind
kernenergie experten
[Musik]
im hinblick auf den wohnungsbau
zweifellos eines der wichtigsten
sozialen anliegen des landes hat nun
angekündigt public private partnerships
also enge kooperation zwischen staat und
privat unternehmen zu fördern und so
sehr in seiner fünfjährigen amtszeit
landes 22 5 millionen wohnungen zu
schaffen davon sollen 1,3 millionen ins
tal gebaut werden gut das wäre schon mal
ein starkes angebot auf der
sozialpolitischen seite auf der
politischen seite gedenkt das genaue
gegenteil von dem zu tun was nun getan
hat
er möchte die bestehenden beschränkungen
für hypotheken lockern und die
kapitalertragssteuer senken außerdem hat
er vorgeschlagen die grundsteuer für
eigentümer mehrerer immobilien zu
novellieren um so die mieten zu senken
und die steuerpolitik für
immobilienbesitzer ist ein thema welches
in südkorea in letzter zeit viel
aufmerksamkeit erhalten hat denn ihr
müsst euch mal folgendes
vergegenwärtigen nach angaben des
koreanischen gewerkschaftsbundes
benötigten 20 jährige südkoreaner im
durchschnitt ein ganzes geschlagenes
jahrhundert um alleine eine normale
wohnung in suhl abzuzahlen laut einer
umfrage von the herald business und in
korea society institute glaubt jeder
vierte wähler dass die stabilität des
wohnungsmarktes die größte
herausforderung für den neuen
präsidenten darstellt
[Musik]
mit der wohnungspolitik allein ist es
jedoch nicht getan denn südkorea ist ein
land mit einer äußerst komplizierten
außenpolitik die südkoreanische
regierung muss sich mit dem
kommunistischen nachbarn im norden
auseinandersetzen um die beziehungen zu
china japan und den vereinigten staaten
sorgfältig austarieren ein balanceakt
der schnell zu kopfschmerzen führen kann
alles deutet darauf hin dass die neue
regierung ihre aussenpolitik zugunsten
der usa und auch japans ändern wird dies
könnte die beziehung zu china natürlich
etwas sagen wir mal abkühlen ich meine
wir wollen hier nicht spekulieren oder
in eine glaskugel schauen allerdings
wirklich der zukünftige kurs des neuen
präsidenten an heinz einer angekündigten
verteidigungspläne ablesen schlägt
jedoch zum beispiel vor dass man den usa
und südkorea stationierte die
raketenabwehrsystem zu verstärkten
dessen stationierung hat südkorea
bereits an den handels und tourismus
boykott von seiten chinas eingebrockt
über den wir bereits in einem früheren
video gesprochen haben dass ich euch
verlinken gerne möchte es trotzdem
riskieren und hofft dass peking heute
nicht mehr über die macht geführt so
aufzumucken wie damals
ich werde das bündnis zwischen korea und
den usa wieder aufbauen und die
umfassende strategische allianz stärken
während wir die grundwerte der liberalen
demokratie der marktwirtschaft und der
menschenrechte teilen ich werde die
bilateralen beziehungen zwischen korea
und china in gegenseitigem respekt
entwickeln und eine zukunftsorientierte
beziehung zwischen korea und japan
schaffen nun gut aber ich weiß was ich
jetzt viele von euch fragen was ist
eigentlich mit nordkorea wie alle
konservativen präsidenten ist auch schon
für eine rückkehr zu einer harten linie
gegenüber pjöngjang
er befürwortet sogar die stationierung
weiterer strategischer waffen durch die
usa er hat jedoch auch deutlich gemacht
dass er zu weiteren friedensgesprächen
bereit ist unabhängig von hughes plänen
der wahrscheinlich ein ständiges
tauziehen zwischen den beiden koreas wie
in den letzten jahrzehnten weiterhin
erleben naja oder vielleicht auch nicht
ich meine wer weiß das schon korea hat
sich schon sehr oft als unberechenbar
erwiesen aber werfen wir abschließend
noch einen blick auf die
wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen die der neue
präsident versprochen hat maßnahmen von
denen er hofft dass sich die
wirtschaftliche vitalität südkoreas
wiederherstellen
nun hat einen schonungslosen kampf gegen
die inflation und ein abbau der
bürokratie angekündigt er möchte die
wirtschaft bis zu 80 vorschriften
befreien und so für eine
flexibilisierung des arbeitsmarktes
orten arbeitnehmer sollen zum beispiel
mit überstunden machen dürfen deren
maximale höhe wurde von seiten der
regierung gedeckelt darüber hinaus hat
er versprochen samsung electronics
tatkräftig dabei zu unterstützen den
rückstand gegenüber taiwans tsmc dem
weltweit größten halbleiterhersteller
aufzuholen
der neue präsident betrachtet die sowohl
aus wirtschaftlicher als auch aus
sicherheitspolitischer sicht als
strategisch sehr wichtig
jungs pläne in bezug auf die
verbleibenden themen sind im moment noch
unklar hierauf visual politik werden wir
das hat genau beobachten wie sich diese
politische kraft wenn sie weiter
entwickelt eine kehrtwende bei der
südkorea einen epochalen wechsel
vollzogen hat von einem präsidenten der
mit obama verglichen wurde zu einem der
mit world trading verglichen wird unser
fokus wird daher weiterhin auf diese
region ruhen und ihr dürft euch schon
bald auf neue videos über die
entwicklungen in den deutlichen
schlüssel ländern wie japan und taiwan
freuen aber jetzt seid ihr erst mal an
der reihe glaubt ihr dass der neue
präsident mit dem nach dem was ihnen
gesehen habt die hauptprobleme südkoreas
beheben kann wird südkorea die art von
wirtschaftlichen renaissance erleben die
jungen vorhersagt was wird mit den
beziehungen zu china und nordkorea
geschehen ist der vergleich mit ronald
reagan übertrieben und falls nicht kann
es nun im neuen tandem mit japans
premier china schaffen das mit china zu
machen was in der sowjetunion geschafft
hat wie immer sind wir schon auf eure
beiträge im kommentarbereich gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat und vielleicht auch etwas
gelernt habt ja gibt es kein leichtes
oder freunden und vergesslich das abo
mit glück ich noch keines unserer videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich wollen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine spende von
euch mit uns hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen in peter link dazu findet
eine beschreibung in dem video was
gutmann bis bald
[Musik]